all right wait what was the code again
681 got it
681 it is hello everybody my name is
markiplier and welcome to
cold call cold call calling someone in
the cold the coldness calling out to you
you calling to someone who is cold
having a cold and then having to make a
phone call there's a cold
call coming from inside the house and
it's makes you cold to the core
am i getting through to you is this
making sense to you is this getting
through that thick skull of yours anyway
this is cold call continue i have not
played this before
ira seeing it from your point of view
surveillance and personal cameras
okay hello
hello okay new game maybe that was the
problem
new game it was probably the trying to
continue
ah oh am i driving
in
this is here frederick hartwell what's
the address
heading there now oh
i like it already gonna call on the
radio while it's cold outside
[Applause]
i love it
i love it it feels like an old new
grounds game oh
oh my god this is like this is like
hitting something in the back of my
brain that's just like oh my god hell
yeah the pleasure centers are lighting
up
oh my god i love this police officer if
anyone's here make yourself known
oh my god it's cold in here really cold
it's cold i gotta make a call i
legitimately have not played a game
like this in ages oh my god
dear adrian i can't believe it's been a
whole year since we last saw her heard
from sarah
i always pray that she is okay even when
it seems hopeless
i hope you are keeping strong for you
and for your children
my beautiful grandchildren as always let
me know if there's anything i can do
all the best mom all right well
everyone's probably dead
hello
call boiler guy spoiler guy you know
when boiler guy walks into the party
everyone's just spoiler guy okay so
nothing here that i see
oh this is creepy locked with a password
huh
lots of camping heaters in every room
right presents
who the hell what was that who the hell
was that
huh make yourself known
hello oh
who's there toolbox oh i don't like this
oh i don't like this at all this is
super creepy oh this is legitimately
creepy
ooh legitimately okay actually creepy
oh fire uh answer emails go shopping
rack presents
your kids up from school decorate tree
order food call estate agent tomorrow
yes sell this place tells the place
immediately
hello okay time to go upstairs
police officer anybody up here anybody
up here anybody up there
anybody help you
that's not a good idea to have that by
the tub it's fools
hello someone's phone
family picture okay
why oh hate it hate it mommy someone's
behind you mommy
okay whoa is that mr hopps
why is mr hopps here legitimately that's
mr hopps
lixie and remind him who mr hopps is but
really quickly and
way too scarily okay cool thank you
all right something doesn't feel right
i'll head back to my cruiser
what the hell
oh thank you going back to my cruiser
time to go home
bye bye bye bye baby okay
would it be up in the room upstairs
hello baby oh
that was weird yeah that was a little
weird okay i'm
out of here
maybe i'll take a quick look at the
electrics why would you take a quick
look at what are you an electrician
you're
clicking the electric what do you mean
check the electric what does that even
mean
the electrics what are the electrics in
the basement maybe
there's like a fuse box or something i
don't know i don't know i don't know
where the electrics are
oh missing sarah evans sarah's been
missing since 2019.
if you have any information call police
or find email info find sarah.com
baby jack i miss these
there's a backyard i did not know that
there was a backyard
oh i thought that was a pile of poo
hello
okay see ya oh this is so creepy
oh electrics electric panel okay
wait okay combination's always like baby
11th of august okay
1108 maybe
nope okay um all right so
the electrics there's got to be a code
in here somewhere buried in these
notes or buried on the walls somewhere
or something like that
three one six two well that's convenient
thank you for that three one six
two hey
well that can't be good something must
be overloading the circuit
something must be do i gotta go ahead
and find out oh
boy okay all right police show yourself
yeah you bet yeah good idea with a gun
i don't know what kind of scream was
that i was totally involuntary
shooter show yourself her i'm gonna
shoot yourself
i think the colt's getting to me yeah
you know that's definitely it that's
definitely it that's definitely it yeah
yeah
definitely so something's overloading
the circuit i got to go find out what it
is can i shut this down
give me the heaters turn those off
their towel here went out the pipes will
freeze if i let the temperature drop any
lower
what why is this your job buddy why is
this your job
this ain't your job call the firemen
department have them light the place on
fire
anybody in here
wait something on the ground over here
you are invited to my birthday party at
bose fun house on 25th of january i hope
you can come
okay
who do the kids keep talking to why is
this house so damn cold
what am i hearing at night is something
there i need to get us all out of this
neighborhood as soon as possible
yeah yeah us good idea i don't see a way
to turn off anything individually is
there something in the backyard maybe
no oh wood
oh oh okay oh
i didn't know that that was my immediate
goal i thought i was still trying to
find some
drain power water no electricity
no sign of anybody yeah no seeing what's
going on what's going on
hello did i hear something buzzing like
a phone
like a phone buzzing
hello who is this
who's on my radio janine is that you
oh how about 1108 maybe this is 1108.
um
so there's got to be something in here
or a round
that has a code to that could be 0811
okay not that i'm a bit of a bumbling
fool in this but i
i will not be swayed
25 january oh 2 501
could be uh
no the hell could it be i've been
through this whole place
i've looked literally everywhere
oh my god what happened what was that
the hell happened
what do you mean you just do that you
just did that you just did that
you just did that how about zero
two people two three zero
two two three how about
four two two three no four three three
two
um
it's only like two five one one
combining them
one one two five one one two five
oh it was you had to take the numbers
of each of the pictures my god that was
obtuse
okay alarm timer go it don't work
broken uh systems airplane mode
unavailable unavailable unavailable
unavailable
pictures let me see your pictures uh 911
call no messages are you almost here
yes you parking up thanks for the lovely
evening i love you i love you too
so much xxxx xxxxxxx
okay is this supposed to help me okay
um
well
[Applause]
a snowman i need to get out of here
right
now a snowman oh so you don't need to go
oh
that's like something's holding you shut
i'll try going out the back
i'll try that i will do wow hey
more like norman yeah officer hardwell
10 33
i need backup at 84 ashington way east
avenue
hurry
damn it i really hope they heard that
yeah thanks janine i know janine's voice
anywhere
you're uh you're uh you're a lifesaver
janine
you'll you save lives there's no way
that thing's gonna let me leave
it really is just a snowman i better
generate as much heat as possible
all right let's go with that logic you
know what i'm okay with that all right
build a [ __ ] all right okay all right
build the flamethrower you got it buddy
you got it
you got it buddy toolbox ah another code
god damn you damn you hint a name
oh how about sarah didn't they lose us
sarah no
uh hint a name okay a name okay okay
there's gotta be a name what was the
name
sarah evans okay how about all together
sarah evans
okay no ah
it's like the perfect number of letters
but whatever okay um either way there's
gotta be
something else to be explored
that's not working anymore it is strange
that only some things are clickable at
some times
so you have to go through everything
again oh what about
charlotte charlotte
oh what do we have here reminder for key
dish
okay 681 got it thanks for your call
earlier
i can take a look at the electrics on
monday i can't be sooner but i'm always
booked up close to christmas okay
charlotte i'm so glad i found you i'm so
glad it's the world against us
too there isn't anything i wouldn't do
to show that my love is true
i'm so glad that we are one i am so
horny
poems like hetty missing person donate
clothes
best holiday destinations order pizza
poems for
gf oh restore all
restore restore
restore all right fine then i don't get
to be a
snooper all right wait what was the code
again 681 got it
681 it is
i feel like i'm losing my mind yeah me
too man
6 eight one got it and i got the key to
the shed baby
heat to the shed baby boink give me a
flame oh
i don't like that judgmental look you're
giving me buddy
this'll do that'll do this will do
that'll do this will do that'll do
that'll do this will do aha okay well
let's see how you like this well this
isn't exactly the flame thrower that i
thought it would be activate all sources
of heat
sure yeah
how are they getting uh power how's
their uh how's their power
is there one in the basement i don't
think so all right snowman
you're really gonna get it this time
i'm missing one
one more somewhere in the front
hey
how do you like me now survive until
backup arrives what do you mean survive
what do you mean survive
i feel like my gun was working better
do i gotta go get more uh oh no what
does that mean
oh
what does that mean what is happening oh
oh my god
oh i see so i absolutely have to keep
things warm okay okay i'm down for this
now we got a game
now we got a game going on now it's a
game oh
okay
what you want what do you want what do
you got what do you got what do you want
what do you got gonna get more firewood
what you think you think you think
you're wrong
you're wrong you're wrong bud you're
wrong
you're wrong
you're wrong oh man five nights at
freddy's prepared me for this
melt baby melt baby there we go
who told you you didn't have to worry
what do you mean what are you talking
about who's worrying about what
who's worrying i'm not worrying i ain't
worried
try me i am fine oh you want this one
well good thing i'm right here good
thing i'm so toasty and warm the fire in
my heart
will heat me through the winter
kids bedroom yeah that's what i thought
easy
easy too easy too easy
too easy i might come across
you want some of this you want some of
this oh you want some of this
yeah you you try you try you try you
ain't getting nothing
yeah well uh didn't sound that way i'm
sorry
i'm really sorry oh yeah yeah yeah okay
yeah bathroom all right yeah sure
yeah sure yeah sure okay yeah sure look
it's getting warmer
oh god oh god oh god up uh bathroom
again oh really you love the bathroom
you think i can't get to the bathroom oh
yeah it's getting warmer in there
nope god damn it hey yeah yeah yeah whoa
whoa whoa
easy there buddy easy there buddy easy
there buddy oh god oh god oh god no ow
put that in there can i did i put it in
there okay up
uh master bedroom okay hang on whoa whoa
we're getting mine
oh wait perfect get more wood oh i got
to get more wood
don't worry i got this
easy done in control
i don't know what who did for what but
it don't matter let me go
let me go baby let me go let me go let
me go ah melt it melted melted melted i
melted that i oh my god finish up and
fix it oh god okay
we're good i probably should melt those
first i should probably definitely focus
on those
i don't think my health is going to go
up
it was all lies yep all of it lies
i lie you lie we he she lie
lilly lalalala
oh they're getting speedy getting speedy
now
[Music]
getting speedy but i'm speedy too high
what's this bunk
whoa what the hell i thought i got that
didn't i get that
[Music]
oh come on where are the police come on
where's the backup back up please back
up please
please oh oh my god
okay oh they got to be here
we're outside well get in here oh thank
god
[Music]
oh okay i can just leave now apparently
oh i'm outside the house
what we don't see you where's the road
where's my car where the hell am i
[Laughter]
[Applause]
oh yeah it made us know all right these
were the last recordings captured
before officer hardwell disappeared
sarah evans case was reevaluated and
more evidence came to light surrounding
adrian evans
who also went missing along with little
emily and jack evans
the strange events of this case became
known as the ashington way mystery
eventually the house was demolished due
to a rapid state of decay
i wasn't done reading that but okay sure
i like that i like that a lot challenge
what's the challenge
oh it's just the end probably just
survive as long as you can i bet
anyway i don't want to do that that's
all good all good that was very good
i like that i like that and this was
sold for a dollar
this was a dollar game and i would say
that is a dollar game that's a hell yeah
dollar game i might even pay two dollars
for that that was pretty good
i love that style i really do it was a
little too reliant on the go find a code
thing
like i really wish there was some
variety would it maybe just pure
exploration
like maybe one code maybe a key here
like the gating of the clicking on
things made it confusing because you had
to like go back to locations and re-scan
through everything to make sure you
could find
and then things that you clicked on
before that didn't work you would have
to click on again in the future
and then then it would work but that
would be hard to know what to do because
obviously if you clicked on it before
and it didn't do anything in my mind in
my gamer brain it was like oh that's
done before but still
critical thoughts aside i love this
style i love it there's a lot to do with
this particular style of gameplay
it is very uh mr hops is this the same
person
moonbit is that is that the same i gotta
look that up now is that the same person
that did mr hopps
oh it is and that's why i liked it
because i really liked mr hop's
playhouse and i like the other one he
did that was
very much in that style was like a mr
hops five nights at freddy's style but
it's just like i do like that
it's a very pleasant way to play a game
there's a lot to like here this was
really cool
i enjoyed this very much it was very
nice mechanics of it aside this was
still very fun i enjoyed it a lot and i
think it was very cool
definitely worth a buck so uh yeah if
you want to play it for yourself check
it out and support indie developers
because sometimes they make really cool
stuff
so thank you everybody so much for
watching let me know what you thought
down in the comments below
and as always i will see you in the next
video
bye-bye
you